hi everyone thank you for coming I know
it's getting late in the day everyone's
energy is probably a little low so i'll
try and keep it lively keep it
interesting so we're here to talk about
analyzing and optimizing so first what
I'm going to do is try and give you a
little bit of motivation like why is
this an interesting topic I mean you've
already been through designing building
and deploying and then I'm going to walk
through a couple of specific scenarios
in you know a fair amount of detail just
to show you some of the useful tools
that we have available to you on the on
the Google cloud platform specifically
some logs analysis with bigquery and
using some machine learning technology
from the open source community on our
platform so motivation great in the
previous session you just launched your
applications so you're done right you
get to pack up and go home you know the
money just starts rolling in and
everything's great well we all know it's
not quite that simple right the as soon
as you launch your application that's
kind of where the real work begins you
know no plan actually survives contact
with the end user right they start using
your stuff in new and interesting ways
that you perhaps didn't anticipate and
so you've got some challenges in this
optimized and analyzed phase where you
want to figure out what's going on what
are your users actually doing with your
product and how do you make your product
better using that information so if you
want to make your product awesome you've
got to keep working after you launch the
product and use the information that
your app is generating and your users
are generating for you and feed that
back to make your stuff even more
awesome so data is very powerful stuff
you know on the left side here under
reporting we see some pretty basic
entry-level stuff like everybody should
be able to know how many users do I have
how much time are they spending with my
stuff am I getting more engagement or
less engagement over time and my you
our users churning out and turning back
in you know so very basic stuff on the
left side that but that's kind of where
you need to start then in the middle we
talked about this a little bit in the
previous session we've got this great
thing where you can like roll out an
experiment to your users and you know
maybe five percent of them see a new UI
or a new feature or some new algorithm
and you want to know is this an
improvement is this not an improvement
well if you don't measure you'll never
know so that's kind of what we're
talking about in the center here and
then on the right side you know this is
the really advanced stuff can you
somehow use your own users behavior how
they interact with your app with your
software and feed that back into your
app to provide them with an even more
delightful experience so that's kind of
the you know the advanced track there
but first I want to give you a warning
this stuff can be tricky you know it's
been said there are lies really bad lies
and statistics now it's not like your
app is out to trick you right it's not
out to show you a chart to deliberately
mislead you but it's this stuff can be
really subtle it's very easy to draw
incorrect conclusions from what you're
seeing so you know be careful this is
why there is now a you know a group of
people in our industry whose business
card if they had such a thing anymore
says data scientist instead of developer
you know they've got a lot of the same
skills and aptitudes and and knowledge
that developers have but instead of you
know building features their core focus
is gaining insights and it's a very
specialized skill set so beware now in
this one session I obviously can't make
you a data scientist I can't make you an
expert in this so that's why I'm going
to focus on these two concrete scenarios
sort of give you a flavor of what this
is all about the first point is i'm
going to show you the best logs analysis
tool I've ever used which is bigquery
and then I'm going to show you how easy
it is to run open source software on our
platform so interactive logs analysis
with bigquery as the slide says big
is awesome in abellana we have an
application that's implemented in App
Engine among other things and it's
generating interesting data that we want
to analyze so unfortunately since we
just unveiled abellana today we don't
have millions and millions and millions
of lines of interesting logs to analyze
for me to show you however lucky for me
in demo land what we've done is we
imported a bunch of wikipedias logs into
bigquery so people could play with them
and see see what see what logs analysis
is like and Wikipedia does get a lot of
traffic so let's take a look so here is
a big query interface excellent and just
to give you a sense of you know what
bigquery is like and the size of data
set we're looking at we've got a very
simple query here we just want to know
how many rows are in this table which is
all the logs from January of 2012 for
all Wikimedia products up so let's run
that let's see what we get and so we're
looking at we're looking at about 1.7
billion rows of data that's pretty good
traffic for one month but you'll notice
here that it says hey that was cashed
well obviously I ran this query earlier
and if all I do is show you queries that
I've already run and it's giving me cash
results that's kind of cheating so I'm
going to go into the options here and
I'm going to turn this off so now it is
not using cash results and we'll do this
again and perhaps somewhat surprisingly
it doesn't actually take that much
longer but now it says something even
more interesting 4.8 seconds 0 bytes
processed well that's really impressive
we can process nothing in 4.8 seconds by
now I'm sure you're convinced that this
is the best query engine in the world
right well what's going on here of
course is it just looked at the table
metadata right it hasn't actually
crunched any of the rows of the table it
didn't even have to look at the rows of
the table to know how many were there so
let's do something where it'll actually
have to look at the rows of the table
so what we're going to do is add
something to our query here where we're
still just going to do a select count
stars the row count we're still going to
the same table we've just added a where
clause and what we're doing is saying we
want the project the wikimedia project
to be w p which is their code for
Wikipedia because they have more than
just Wikipedia Wikipedia is just the
thing everybody knows about and language
english so now we want to say how many
rows in this data set are actually for
english wikipedia out of the 1.7 billion
i think we saw before so let's run that
and see if we process more than 0 bytes
and we do great amazingly it still took
about the same amount of time which is
kind of interesting like it took us zero
or four points X 4 seconds or so to
process 0 bytes now we're doing 13.3
gigabytes in 4.2 seconds which is a
little more impressive so maybe now
you're thinking okay this might be
something I want to use and we got about
a half a billion rows so now we're
playing with a half a billion rows okay
that's interesting now let's do
something that might actually be
impressive what we're going to do now is
do kind of a kind of an interesting
query so we're adding a couple things
here now it's not just select count star
now what we're doing is we're saying all
right I want to select the title of each
of the title of each of the page views
and I want to some across the number of
views so basically what I'm going to get
here is a list of pages and how many
times they were viewed in the month of
January in 2012 okay that's that's great
but down here I've added something even
more interesting which is a regular
expression match I'm only interested in
the pages where the title matches this
regular expression which in English
means it starts with an uppercase G
there's a lowercase o somewhere in the
middle of the word and it ends with a
lowercase e and I can think of at least
one word that fits that description and
at the bottom we're just finishing off
the with the group by title and order by
views so basically what we're going to
get is a you know we're going to see the
top results first so let's run this one
now I just want to make note here
13.3 gigabytes is with the previous
query processed so now this will
probably take a little bit longer just
doing a little more work after all i'm
running a regular expression over a half
a billion rows right now oh it's done so
that's faster than grep for sure much
faster than grab so but look at this now
it processed 72 points seven gigabytes
in eight point eight seconds so what's
going on why did this process more data
than the previous query well we added a
column right we added this title column
to to the query so it had to look at
more data to do what I was asking it to
do well that's great I mean half a
billion rows that's pretty impressive
going through 72 gigabytes of data in
eight seconds that's pretty impressive
but it's not quite impressive enough I
don't think I've convinced you yet that
this is the greatest logs analysis tool
in history quite yet so let's look at
six months of logs so this is the first
six months of 2012 and this is the same
query as but not not the one I just ran
but the one previous that just tells me
how many rows am I going to be looking
at and what you can see here is in the
the rest of the query is exactly the
same all I've done is add in the from
section I'm referencing six tables this
is actually a very common pattern with
how people put their logs into bigquery
they you know depending on how large and
their logs are and how much traffic they
get they will you know do one month per
table or one day per table for example
and then you can and what bigquery
allows you to do is say well I want you
to look at these six tables or these ten
tables or these 20 tables so it's like
it's one big table when you use this
syntax so let's give that a go now we're
going to go over well let's find out how
many rows we're going to go over now
this took like four seconds before and
now we're doing six times the data so it
should take six times as long right well
that math didn't work but you know six
seconds seventy eight gigabytes and
we're looking now at almost 3 billion
rows okay so let's run a regular
expression across three billion rows so
we have
we have our same query here as before
we're going to do the aggregation we
were talking about but we're hitting the
six months worth of data and we're doing
the same regular expression so again
this took what 89 seconds last time so
it should take six times as long right
so six times as long that would be you
know about 40 50 seconds right that's
that's kind of what if it's scaled
linearly that's what we would be
expecting to happen but it only takes 12
seconds and it processed 430 gigabytes
that's almost a half a terabyte in 11.7
seconds I mean just reading this much
data off a hard drive the best hard
drive you can find is going to take like
17 18 minutes i think i did the math a
little while back on that because i
wanted to know like i mean is this is
this really that impressive but you buy
the best fastest SSD you can you read
the data from it as fast as you can it's
still going to take you nearly 20
minutes just to read it much less
running the aggregations and the regular
expressions and all that and bigquery
did it in less than 12 seconds so
hopefully by now you agree with me if I
could switch back to the slides please
that bigquery is awesome so how is it
that bigquery can do this awesome thing
I just showed you what is that what is
this magic where I throw six times as
much data to add it nearly half a
terabyte you know what was it three
billion rows and it runs this regular
expression across three billion rows in
less than 12 seconds how does it do this
thing well back in 2010 we published his
paper on something called drummer Dremel
is the internal name for the technology
that became bigquery and this was
developed to do exactly what I just
showed you it's developed to do
interactive scale analysis interactive
speed analysis of the huge data sets we
had to deal with at Google so what do I
mean by interactive interactive means
well in this context it means I can
stall up here on stage long enough for
the query to end right in this context
that's what interactive means but in a
real context what it means is you don't
feel
need to get up from your desk and go get
a coffee well your while your query runs
or worse yet switch off to that other
project that you have on the back burner
and bring it to the front burner and you
know completely lose your productivity
interactive means it's fast enough that
you don't lose your train of thought so
there's a few key points that I want to
cover that are in this paper I encourage
you to go read it it's great reading
there's a few key points I want to cover
from this paper that will help you
understand where bigquery is really
going to shine like where you should
really use it so the first is bigquery
uses this multi-level serving tree this
is a if you think about the regular
expression that we were just talking
about this is a classic
divide-and-conquer sort of problem I can
just take my three billion rows chop it
up into lots and lots of little pieces
you know and then farm it out to all
these leaf nodes where each leaf node
can process its little piece of the
problem in a few seconds right and then
it can say well of the hundred thousand
rows of the million rows you gave me
here are the few that matched this
regular expression and they pass that up
to these intermediate servers and then
the intermediate servers can you know
bring these these subsets together but
in this case we're not actually passing
back up in the query i showed you we're
not passing back up the actual matching
rows what we're doing is we're counting
the rows that match so the leaf nodes do
all that counting and then they just
pass up their counts to the intermediate
servers which then just add those counts
together which is really fast computers
add pretty well and eventually it gets
up to the root server and we have our
answer so this multi-level serving tree
is you know sort of where that magic
happens that's that's why you can
imagine when we went from a half a
billion rows to six billion rows the
reason it only got a little bit longer
was because this tree got so much wider
we just split the data up into way way
way more pieces and they still took
about the same amount and then we took a
little extra time in the intermediate
servers because they had a little more
work to do to combine all these sub
pieces so the takeaway from this is
bigquery
shines when your output set is much much
much smaller than your input set and
there is a huge number of very useful
queries that meet that description for
example the whole needle in this
haystack thing it's like yeah I remember
doing this when I worked on cloud
storage you know we would we would be
trying to debug a problem with a
particular object and I would I could go
through months worth of logs and say
show me everything that ever happened to
this particular object and I could see
when it was created when it was accessed
and so on and then figure out what
happened and that's really powerful
because I was able to go over these
billions of rows and records and just
extract just the information that was
relevant to my problem that's the sort
of thing you know we use Dremel for
internally and that you could use
bigquery for over your logs aggregation
is another example of this type of query
where you're looking at a lot of data
but you're actually bubbling up
relatively small amounts of information
the second piece of technology that
underpins Dremel and thus bigquery is
column-oriented storage so in a lot of
really useful data sets you have a lot
of columns maybe hundreds of columns and
if you're storing them like you see on
the left here in a row oriented way even
if you're only interested in a few of
those columns you have to read the whole
row off of disk throw that most of that
data way and then read the information
you are interested in if instead you can
somehow figure out a way to store the
columns together instead of the rows and
you're only interested in five out of
100 columns you just read those five
columns and that's it another similar
example is sometimes the data is very
sparse in that there's a column that
only appears in one percent of your
records for example but if you store it
as rose you have to read the whole road
just to find it oh this one doesn't have
the column you store them in this column
format then suddenly you only look at
the data you need now you remember I
made a point of saying when we added the
title column to our query suddenly the
amount of data we processed went from
like 13 gigabytes to 70 gigabytes or
something like that 78 that's where
that's where you can see this
column-oriented storage in action
bigquery only looks at the data it needs
to look
to answer the question you asked it so
when I asked about the title suddenly it
had to look at more data and it's
telling me how much it needed to look at
now the trick with doing this well is
being able to efficiently translate
between row and column oriented storage
and if you're interested in how that
works I can't really explain it but the
paper does a great job of that so we
talked about the multi-level serving
tree we talked about the column oriented
storage if you're someone who has worked
with large analytical databases before
of a certain type or if you're somebody
who's got a lot of relational database
experience you're probably asking
yourself sure but what he did before
this talk was he created indexes on
those things that he was querying on
well here's the thing for this large
class of queries where the output is
much much smaller than the input you
don't need if you use these two tricks
if you use the multi-level serving tree
and you use the column art it's oriented
storage you don't need to have an index
you just look at all of the data and you
get your answer and you can do it really
really fast as I've shown you so this
allows you you don't have to decide in
advance well these are the interesting
columns and in this order you don't need
to figure that out before you start
asking your questions you just start
asking your questions bigquery looks at
the data it needs to look at to answer
them in a very fast and efficient way
and then you just follow your data where
it leads you so the demo I showed was
the bigquery browser that's the thing in
the top left here and it's a great tool
it's the best way to get started with
bigquery and see what it can do for you
but at its core bigquery is not that you
I I showed you bigquery is an API
bigquery is a service that you access
through this API so that means not only
is there's this big query browser that I
showed you but there's a command-line
tool so if you're the type of person who
thinks the mouse is the device you use
to point the console in which you want
to type then you're probably going to
like the command line tool if you're the
sort of person who lives and breathes
and and and is in Excel all day long
creating reports and generating
spreadsheets we've got a connector for
Excel where you can pull like
run a big query query and pull the
results into Excel now of course because
it's an API we're not the only people
who can build cool UI on top of it so
there's this long list of people in the
in the middle here who have integrated
their products with bigquery and at the
top of that list is tableau and down in
the vendor expo you can find they've got
a spot set up there and just the other
day Jeff down there was showing me this
fantastic demo of analyzing the g dealt
data set which we have another one of
the interesting public data sets that's
in bigquery with this great you know geo
visualization and colors and all sorts
of stuff you know I encourage you to go
take a look at it's really cool stuff
and then finally on the right side here
is whatever you guys build remember it's
an API that means you can write code to
submit queries so you're not limited to
what we build or what some third-party
built you can build your own dashboards
for your own business you can integrate
this into your products if you want to
so hopefully you're sold right you agree
with me that bigquery rocks you want to
use it to analyze your application and
see what's going on but there's one
downer and in fact an audience member
pointed this out in the previous session
you know he asked the very great
question it's like so how do i get my
App Engine logs into bigquery and the
answer was come to this session and
we'll tell you all about it so now
that's what i'm going to do in the
context of avellana we've got some App
Engine logs for that that server is
creating we've also got some interesting
data in the data store that you might
want to link to those logs you know like
for example the the users you have what
photos they've chosen to like and so on
and we also you'll recall from the
previous sessions that abellana reads
and writes photos directly from cloud
storage not via App Engine like the the
the android app interact directly with
cloud storage so cloud storage also has
logs that you probably want to analyze
so you want to get all of these things
into bigquery so you can do the sorts of
things I was just
showing you so how do we do that well
this is where stuff gets real right
that's at some future date I want to
give a version of this presentation
where I can say go click these three
check boxes and it'll all show up
unfortunately today is not the day I get
to give that presentation today is the
day where I tell you there's a little
bit of work to do to input to to load
this data into bigquery fortunately we
have published some best practices about
these about how to do this so I'm going
to walk you through those now and then
give you a pointer on you know how you
can stay up to date as these things get
better over time I think the there was a
question about well how soon will this
be automatic and somebody who runs that
team gave the answer you know sometime
this year i think the comment was it'll
be a Christmas present so let's talk
about the easiest one first cloud
storage so bigquery already loads data
from cloud storage what I mean is if you
want to put your data into cloud storage
if you have some big file you want to
analyze with bigquery you upload it to
cloud storage and then do a load job
into bigquery so that's sort of a normal
way to load your data so what you can do
with cloud storage is there's a feature
where you can just enable log delivery
and you you tell cloud storage hey I
want to know everything that's going on
in this bucket here so we might do the
Abbey Lana in and the abellana out
buckets say I want to know everything
that's going on in these two buckets and
I want you to put those logs in this you
know a bail on allods bucket and then
every hour a new object will show up in
that bucket which contains all the
activity that happened on the other ones
then you can run a load job get that
into bigquery and do the sorts of things
I was showing you so next up let's talk
about App Engine logs in this case what
you need to do there's a log street API
you need to use their map the App Engine
MapReduce library to do a MapReduce over
that logs API get that data into cloud
storage in a format that can be loaded
into bigquery fortunately you don't have
to write this from scratch in fact two
people have already written it for you
there are two open source projects one's
called log log to be Q and the other
one's called mash or mache I'm not sure
how they like to pronounce it
that will do exactly this pattern for
you one's written in Python ones written
in Java choose your favorite language
and go then finally cloud datastore this
is where we have our users and likes
information that we want to import in
you may be noticing a pattern here it's
like do a MapReduce get it into cloud
storage load it into bigquery in this
case we don't have an open source
project I can point you to but we do
have a code lab which basically walks
you through it step by step so those are
the patterns that's the best practices
that's what you can do when you leave
this door tonight go home and and this
will work this is what we you can do
today hopefully very soon sounds like
perhaps this quarter at least some of
this will start to get easier and I
expected to get easier and easier over
time so when in doubt go read the docs
everything I just told you in the
previous three slides was pulled
directly from this documentation page
watch this space for updates because
this is where you'll find out that oh by
the way now it's just a check box so our
first example is complete hopefully you
know I've made a good case for how
bigquery is a great tool for analyzing
your logs and giving you some pointers
on on how to get to the place where you
can do that now let's talk about
something completely different so I
B'Elanna has this thing called a photo
feed and in fact earlier today in the
second session princess talked about how
you know today AB you Lana assembles
this photo feed in a fairly well how
would I describe it it's kind of a
straightforward thing it's like well you
follow these people they upload photos
therefore it shows up in your photo feed
right and it's just strictly
chronological well this is a this is a
wonderful opportunity to to improve the
user experience through watching their
behavior right can we can we come up
with some clever way of deciding what
things show up in the photo feed higher
and lower or which show up and don't
show up at all that will that will tend
to show people images that delight them
versus images that bore them
so this has a huge impact on the
experience people are going to have with
this this application it's a really big
deal so everyone in this audience could
probably come up with fantastic ideas
for how to make this better right you
could if you're if you're an image
processing person then you're probably
going to say well you could extract all
these features and you know photos that
are brighter that are outdoor stuff you
know those are always going to be big
hits photos with people in them or maybe
you want to detect cats because everyone
loves cats and we'll just promote all
the cat photos to the top of the feed
you know everybody could have an idea
for this and they're all good ideas
right and you could actually implement
some of them and you could do the a/b
testing we were talking about where you
deploy this as an experiment and see
well do people click you know do more
likes when I use this algorithm versus
that algorithm but for today what we're
going to do is talk about collaborative
filtering collaborative filtering is a
class of machine learning algorithm that
is used to predict user preferences so
for example you're on a retail site and
you choose to purchase item a and
generally speaking you get a list of
other items that that retailer would
love to sell you that they think you
might be interested in because you are
interested in item a the way they do
that is they notice that people who buy
item a they kind of often buy items B
and C as well this is a classic
collaborative filtering task a similar
scenario is if you're on a movie site
and you know you rate movie a with 5
stars then it might suggest some other
movies you might like and they know that
because other users who rated this movie
5 stars also rated those other movies
highly so for example the netflix prize
competition was a collaborative
filtering machine learning competition
so what we have in abellana is photos
and likes right users can click like on
a photo if there are other users around
that have a tendency to like the same
photos that you do then when they like a
photo it's kind of a good bet that you
might like that photo and so we could
come up with a collaborative filtering
model which could then promote these
images that we think you're likely to
like higher in your feed but the
news is I don't have a PhD in machine
learning so I can't write a
collaborative filtering algorithm it's
alien would be touch and go if i were to
even like read a paper and try and
implement a collaborative filtering
algorithm because this stuff is you know
difficult to understand difficult to
write and really difficult to verify
that it's working properly so what I
want is a library that somebody else is
written somebody who does a PhD and this
stuff is written and has tested and has
been used elsewhere and I know it works
that's what I'm looking for so this is
where open source can help a lot you
know you do you do a little bit of
google searching and you find out hey
there's this thing called ml lib which
has a collaborative filtering algorithm
in it and it runs on this thing called
spark which runs on Hadoop so all I
needs a spark cluster where do I get a
spark cluster well that I can help you
with so let's deploy spark on Hadoop two
different ways we're going to do it the
easy way and we're going to do it the
even easier way so here is the easy way
so this is using a utility that Google
created called BTU till stands for big
data utility which is its purpose in
life is to deploy Hadoop clusters on our
infrastructure and I'm and I'm telling
it to add this extension spark shark
which tells it oh by the way I want my
Hadoop cluster to also have spark on it
I configured a file earlier which tells
it you know my the bucket I wanted to
use the project what what zone is should
be in what machine types to use how many
worker nodes and stuff like that this is
all pretty pretty close to the default
settings so I'll just let that start so
what it's doing now is it's going to
create these VMs SSH into them install
all the Hadoop stuff on it install all
the spark stuff on it for me and then
when it's done I should have a fully
functioning cluster but it's going to
take a few minutes so while that's
running what I'm going to do is show you
the even easier way to do this which
would be using
click to deploy which you saw earlier in
France s talk where he did a click to
deploy of Redis on our service so down
here in the compute section under
compete sorry click to deploy we can see
Apache Hadoop and as France s noticed
earlier it's actually two clicks you
know because you gotta click go first
then you have to click deploy cluster in
this case sure US Central 1a is fine to
work your nodes will be fine tell it the
bucket I want to use and look at that
there's a checkbox for install apache
spark that is so convenient down here
you can see that if you want to you can
use larger or smaller instances for
reasons that hopefully I'll be able to
explain later high memory instances can
be particularly interesting for spark
clusters or clusters where you intend to
run spark but I'm just going to leave
all this stuff as default for now and
click deploy cluster so deployment may
take three to ten minutes we've got 17
and a half left so hopefully before the
end of the talk this will be done so I'm
just going to leave that running come
back over here and we can see alright
it's the script has successfully created
the VMS and it's now in the process of
installing the hadoop the hadoop
software on these notes so while this is
running i'm going to switch back to the
presentation please and talk just a
little bit more about what it is we're
setting up here so we have these two
clusters coming up what is this what is
this stuff that i'm i'm currently
bringing up well let's go back in time a
little bit 2003 google publishes a paper
on something called the Google file
system the the Google file system is a
cluster level distributed file system
this is something that any serious
distributed computation over very large
data sets you've got to have a
distributed file system to do that
because if you're if you're always
trying to go back to one machine or one
file server or one sequel server or
something like that it's never going to
scale to the truly large
two large data sets and then in 2004 we
published another paper I'll MapReduce
which provided a programming model which
was really useful for a large variety of
workloads search indexing being one of
them which ran on the Google file system
and did a lot of good stuff for us but
if you didn't work at Google you didn't
get to play with these toys so the open
source community said hey this stuff
looks good we want some so they started
to implement things that looked a lot
like the Google file system and looked a
lot like mapreduce and there was a
variety of implementations but the most
popular one of course is Hadoop and so
Hadoop at its core is an implementation
of MapReduce with an implementation of a
distributed file system called HDFS
which looks a whole lot like gfs did and
you can't spend very long around talking
about Hadoop before encountering all of
these references to elephants and so on
so that's why I put the logo up here so
you could see okay that's where all the
elephant references come from now of
course at Google gfs and MapReduce were
great but they weren't sufficient right
that's not everything that we have there
you know I've already talked about I've
already talked about Dremel right but we
also have this thing called big table
another thing called megastore another
thing called spanner another thing
called chubby all of them fill in
different niches in this large-scale
distributed computing space so similarly
in the open source world people don't
talk about Hadoop as just MapReduce and
a distributed file system they talk
about Hadoop as an entire ecosystem of
things each of which does its own very
specialized thing so I could go through
each of these things and tell you what
they are and that wouldn't be much good
to you for the purposes of this talk
these are the ones we're talking about
like the core Hadoop distribution HDFS
which is the distributed file system and
spark which is the thing that has this
library that we wanted wanted to use so
what has google added to this
right how we made it better to run
Hadoop on our platform then perhaps to
like buy a bunch of machines and rack
them and run them on your space well the
first thing we've done is we've built
these connectors that you can use to
read and write from our managed storage
services from your Hadoop jobs HDFS is
not just a file system implementation
but it's also an interface that all
these pieces all those buzzwords you saw
in that previous slide use to talk to
the data storage layer so our datastore
these connectors basically make our
storage services look just like the
native HDFS filesystem so all of those
buzzwords can read and write from our
storage services just like they were
reading and writing from the native HDFS
filesystem this is super powerful for
two reasons one you know we're bringing
up a brand new cluster right now in the
background when that cluster is up the
HDFS filesystem will be completely empty
that means in order to do any useful
work the first thing you have to do is
import all your data into HDFS and then
you can actually do something useful if
your data is already sitting in cloud
storage you can completely skip that
step you can just start doing useful
work reading the data from cloud storage
and the second reason that's powerful is
because when you're done processing your
data if you do it with the native HDFS
filesystem then you have all this output
sitting in your file system and you have
to keep your cluster up just so you can
read your data so you're paying for all
of these CPU and memory resources that
you're not using that are sitting idle
just so you can read from your
distributed file system if instead you
write your final results back to Google
Cloud storage as soon as your job is
done you just tear down the cluster and
then you're paying nothing so you only
pay for the computation you need so and
as I mentioned earlier this applies not
just a MapReduce jobs but to all those
things you saw in the previous slide so
the other thing we've done is the two
things I demoed earlier which is beating
you till big data utility and click to
deploy click to deploy is a great place
to start right it brings up a totally
functional cluster that you can go in
and kick the tires and play around with
it's it's easy to bring the clusters up
it's easy to bring
down so that's a great place to start if
you have if you have some more advanced
scenarios in mind like like I really
like this one this one thing or I want
to customize it in this one specialized
way BTW utils probably the place you're
going to end up eventually because it is
a script you can go in there and modify
it you can create your own extensions
like you saw the spark extension i used
it's also obviously its command line
tool so it's very very scriptable so
finally what is spark now because I
talked I've sort of told you well Hadoop
is the MapReduce and HDFS is gfs but I
haven't told you what spark is sparks
relatively new it was developed down
here in the bay area in the Berkeley amp
lab and has since been transferred to
become its own top level Apache project
the key concept in spark is this thing
called a resilient distributed data set
or RDD what what they were attempting to
to do with spark is is they looked at
the they looked at the the pattern of
computations that didn't fit the
traditional MapReduce model very well
and they said you know what we'd love to
do is sort of pull all this data into
memory and then iterate on it really
fast right we think that the working set
on this calculation is small enough that
we can actually fit not on the memory of
one machine but we can fit it in the
memory of a large cluster so how do we
distribute this data set across all of
these nodes in a resilient way such that
if a node goes down it's not lost we can
still read it from secondary storage and
bring it back up so the RDD is all about
how they make that work this is a huge
win for certain types of workloads
particularly this iterative workload
where you're going over and over and
over the same data often and machine
training machine learning models tends
to be a very iterative thing so this
model works really well for machine
learning so now we have more buzz words
right because spark is starting to build
its own ecosystem around itself one is
spark
used to be called shark that's sequel
like interface so if your data set will
fit into memory on your cluster then you
can run these sequel queries across it
very very quickly now if it doesn't fit
into memory you can still run the
queries it's just going to be a little
slower there's a streaming streaming
processing library there's a graph
processing library and there's this
thing called ml lip which is the thing
we actually wanted you know at the start
of this presentation and it includes the
alternating least squares ALS
collaborative filtering algorithm and
because this is running on Hadoop it
reads and writes from HDFS so it can
read and write from via all our
connectors so demo time what I'd like to
show you is how I was able to take this
library and build collaborative
filtering into abellana and then you're
all going to take out your phones you're
going to see this awesome delightful you
know set of photos based on your
personal preferences and so on but I'm
not that good so what I'm actually going
to do is just show you that we have in
fact brought up a fully functioning
spark cluster here and I'm going to do
that by walking through a slightly
modified version of the collaborative
filtering example that's in the spark
documentation so what we see on the
screen now is the end of my BD util run
and I can see that it has completed and
it looks like it completed successfully
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to beat you till as this nice feature
where it can bring up a socks proxy for
you and then if you point a browser to
this socks proxy running on your local
machine it proxies all those requests
over to your compute engine network so
that you can do something that looks
like this and lo and behold you're
looking at the spark master on your
cluster and you're doing it by name
notice in the wow that's small up there
in the upper left corner it actually
says Hadoop dash am I didn't have to do
that by IP address that makes it really
easy to do things like click on these
links and all these links will just work
you don't have to open
up any ports on your firewall you don't
have to cut copy and paste IP addresses
and things like that so here we have our
spark cluster and because I'm not nearly
as good as France esque is I'm actually
going to have to copy and paste my my
examples so let's use the BD you tell
shell command which is just shorthand
for please SSH me into the master node
of my Hadoop cluster and then I'm going
to just show you the very small test
data set that we're using for this
example so what we have going on here is
each row the first number is the user ID
the second number is an item and the
third number is a rating so user number
one rated item number two a one user
number 1 rates item number 3 of 5 and so
on this data set was chosen such that
user one is a lot like user to and
nothing like user three and four so I
should be able to throw the algorithm at
this and it will be able to tell me will
user one like item one so let's see if
we can do that I will fire up something
called the spark shell and the spark
shell gives me a scala prompt which
interacts with the cluster there we have
it so if i go over to my my master node
here I'll see hey look I've got a
running application now it's called
spark shell and it's taken four cores
and it has nearly 12 gigs of memory per
node right so I now this spark shelled
which has access to all the resources on
my cluster but I'm interacting with it
like I was just you know sort of typing
on a local machine so that's kind of
cool so let's just import some
libraries will need there's the ALS
library that we're looking for there we
go e and now let's load our data so look
we have an RDD it has just pulled that
file out of cloud storage and it is
turned it into a resilient distributed
data set that can be used by spark well
that's kind of cool so let's go over
here and see what the spark shell did to
do that well that's kind of interesting
it hasn't doesn't seem to have done
anything right because there's no
nothing completed nothing failed well I
guess just reading doesn't count so
let's try something else here will
transform that into a format that is
suitable for actually building the model
so that must have done something no okay
well I I can get behind that now we're
going to train the model so this is
actually building the machine learning
model off of our data set so please
train that model well look at all that
output it must have done something now
right still nothing so at this point I'm
getting a little confused right it's
it's like how is it that I trained a
model and spark still hasn't actually
done any work this doesn't make any
sense to me and and this is one of the
really interesting things about spark
spark does not actually do any work
until you ask you to question that it
can't answer without doing that work all
it's done so far it's basically said
okay at some point in the future you
might ask for that our DD well I know
where to get it I know how to make it
right because you told me go read it
from this file and at some point you
might actually asked me to use this
model you told me to train but you
haven't asked me to use it yet so I'm
not going to go train it until you
actually want me to use it now what I'm
going to do is ask it for a prediction
I'm going to ask it please predict what
user one will think of item number one
and if this works I should get an answer
that's close to five because that would
be consistent with the other user that
that sort of liked the same thing
so let's ask it for this prediction now
we see tons of output and if we go over
here we'll find now we've got things
going on right here are all the steps
that it basically cued up and said okay
when you ask me for something I know
what to do I know how to create this
answer and you can see even though this
isn't a difficult like the input set
wasn't huge it actually distributed that
load over all 8 cores on my little baby
cluster and if we click on one of these
these jobs or these stages as they call
them we can see all these statistics
about you know what it was doing and how
long it took and so on so let's go back
and see what our answer was and indeed
we got an answer that was pretty close
to five so we have a fully functioning
spark cluster so the point of this demo
was not that that was the most awesome
machine learning demo ever the real core
the demo was hey look how easy it is to
pull these cool resources into your
computing world and start to play with
them but the last thought I'd like to
leave you with is that there's more than
one way to do it so I spent a lot of
time in this presentation talking about
how awesome bigquery is at analyzing
logs but you know what there's a lot of
people who are doing a lot of great work
analyzing logs using some of the open
source technologies that were on one of
the previous slides you know it's a
perfectly valid way to do that and if
you want to do that on our cloud
platform we'd love to have you do it
here and similarly even though i was
showing how you can use these great
machine learning libraries from the open
source community on our cloud platform
you know at a at a previous previous
show at Google i/o Felipe Hoffa over
here did this fantastic demo where they
were showing how they were going to
predict the outcome of World Cup soccer
games using bigquery so you can do
machine learning on bigquery too there's
more than one way to do it so my goal
wasn't to say for logs analysis you must
use bigquery and for machine learning
you must use spark that's not the point
at all what I was hoping to do with this
presentation is inspire you to analyze
and optimize
your application that's and give you
some starting points like these are good
basic starting points where you can
begin experimenting and if you take
these tools and you think about your
data and you get it into a form where
you could do this analysis and
optimization you can really make your
app awesome over time thank you very
much